wir wissen seit dem wochenende von der
kanzlerin dass die flüchtlingskrise
diese große krise die wir alle in den
letzten jahren erlebt haben nicht nur in
deutschland sondern in ganz europa gar
keine krise war die kanzlerin hat in
einem interview mit der süddeutschen
zeitung gesagt ich vermeide das wort
flüchtlingskrise sie hat ja das wort ja
nicht in den mund genommen aus prinzip
da für mich ein flüchtling keine krise
ist sondern ein mensch das hat hier nie
jemand bezweifelt dass die flüchtlinge
menschen sind das versteht sich von
selbst aber es weiß ja auch jeder dass
diese situation ab 2015 eigentlich score
2015 eine riesige krise war und ist und
nur weil die kanzlerin meint dass das
keine krise sei das macht die sache
nicht weniger kompliziert da braucht man
ja nur in die lager in der türkei
schauen oder nach jordanien oder nach
libanon schauen wo es viel mehr
flüchtlinge gibt als in deutschland und
das zu verstehen wo man könnte die
flüchtlinge die in dem lager in moria
waren die das lager in brand gesetzt
haben vor einem jahr ungefähr fragen ob
sie das alles krise gesehen haben und
die glaubt sie würden zu einem anderen
ergebnis kommen als die kanzlerin die
flüchtlingskrise ist leider noch nach
wie vor mit uns kostet europa milliarden
hat europa gespalten und hat dazu
geführt dass deutschland jetzt mit einer
rechten partei zu tun hat und wir leben
hier alle noch mit den folgen und mit
der gegenwart dieser krise
ich muss aufpassen weil ich weiss jedes
mal wenn ich über flüchtlinge spreche
dann habe ich mit
teilweise morddrohungen zu tun und vor
allem werde ich als ahmad man so als
nazi bezeichnet weil ich nicht denn
toleranz mitbringen die man von mir
erwartet sache nichts hinzu
zu können oder nicht sehen zu wollen und
nicht nur das positive an
an die flüchtlinge sondern auch die
herausforderungen die wir als
gesellschaft haben und wir haben eine
herausforderung erstmal menschen die
ihre länder verlassen weil sie vom krieg
betroffen sind weil sie mit ihren kinder
fliehen weil sie wege nehmen die ihr
leben gefährden und wir haben gesehen
wie viele menschen auch im
meer ertrinken leider ist eine krise
menschen die anders sozialisiert sind in
eine neue gesellschaft kommen
gezwungenermaßen nach europa gekommen
sind ist eine krise menschen die mit
werte der freiheit überfordert sind ist
eine krise das ist eine herausforderung
für uns alles gesellschaft und ich sehe
eigentlich
symbolisch was merkel sie sagen will sie
ist auf eine sehr ideologischen weg was
flüchtlingspolitik angeht sie hat jahr
2015 viel kritik bekommen und ich glaube
ihre art und weise mit diese kritik
umzugehen das ganze in eine positive
licht zu sehen aber ich erwarte von
einem politiker in deutschland
dass er in der lage oder wie in der lage
sein soll das positive aber vor allem
auch die herausforderung die damit
verbunden sind zu sehen wirklich also
ich muss ehrlich sagen warum angela
merkel das nicht als krise definiert das
verstehe ich nicht denn das war die
größte krise ihrer kanzlerschaft dafür
war auch dass dadurch auch die bis heute
anhält und die wurde nicht gemanagt bis
heute eigentlich nicht gemeldet und es
ist ja auch keine kohärente politik von
ihr also man kann ja nicht sagen dass
sie dass sie sich weiterhin als
flüchtlings kanzlerin lässt sie sich
feiern immer noch natürlich und
hochleben aber gleichzeitig macht sie
deals mit adler und mit anderen die
verhindern sollen dass weiter
flüchtlinge zu uns kommen
genau das gleich also ist das jetzt ein
problem und es ist kein problem wenn
menschen nicht das problem sind und wenn
es keine krise war dann müsste man auch
diese krise einfach dadurch lösen dass
man diese leute zu uns lässt lässt man
auch nicht also wenn sie bei dieser
logik geblieben wäre dieser anspricht
hätte sie auch diese flüchtlinge
aufnehmen ist das grundproblem ist ja
dass wir bis heute kein richtiges
einwanderungsgesetz haben was uns in die
lage versetzt die menschen so das muss
man einfach sagen wie kanada
beispielsweise dann auch zu behandeln
dass man sagt die und die kommen zu uns
und die müssen bitteschön zurück und das
wir grenzen an den außengrenzen der
europäischen union so belastbar sichern
dass man sagen kann nur diejenigen die
ein berechtigtes interesse eine sache
dürfen wir nicht vergessen das thema
wurde zu einem moral frage gemacht schon
2015 und jeder der irgendwie ein
kritiker ausland wieder afd oder nazi
oder rechtsradikal und dadurch war die
kritik nicht möglich merkel hat in ihrem
stab menschen die moralisch in diese
richtung auch seit 2005 gearbeitet haben
die übrigens auch was integrations
angeht was der kampf gegen rassismus
angeht in eine bestimmte richtung gehen
der sehr links ist das sind wichtige
themen aber man kann sie auch anders
behandelt und ich glaube dass es sehr
konsequenz dass sie das nicht als krise
wird weil das passt wunderbar zu ihre
einstellungen der letzten fünf jahren
und das ist schade weil sie schadet
damit natürlich das konservative in ihre
partei und hat wahrscheinlich auch dann
sozusagen die cdu auch die die regierung
gekostet ich glaube sie weiß ja genau
dass dies eine krise ist also die will
das wort natürlich nicht in den mund
nehmen gerade deswegen weil sie vor
einem scherbenhaufen steht in wahrheit
und wenn man sich wirklich intensiv mit
diesem thema auseinander selbst wie du
das gemacht hat
dann sieht man dass nichts gelöst ist
die flüchtlinge die million die nach
deutschland gekommen ist die sind ja da
das ist ja super man kann das super
finden oder schlecht finden oder wie
auch immer aber eine krise bleibt es ja
allemal vor allem in der europäischen
union das ist ein aspekt
der leider in deutschland zu viel zu
wenig beachtet wird wie sehr dieses
thema flüchtlinge europa
zu verhalten haben und
die rechten und polen wo und in ungarn
und auch in österreich bisher also die
leben und konnte in frankreich das wären
wir nächstes jahr reißen die leben von
diesem thema also das hat diese ängste
geschürt weil merkel merkel im
alleingang diese entscheidung getroffen
hat damals und sich gedacht hat wir
werden halt das nachher mit den
europäischen partnern regeln also wir
deutsche wir entscheiden jetzt im
alleingang und die anderen werden uns
wollen ja und die sind den deutschen
leider oder gott sei dank nicht gefolgt
je nachdem wie man das sieht aber ich
finde das ist wirklich bedauerlich dass
dass sie das jetzt in den letzten tagen
ihrer kanzlerschaft dass sie sich so
ausgedrückt hat also das thema ist
leider ist zu groß um das noch in
wenigen sekunden abzuhandeln ich möchte
nur zu protokoll geben dass ich schon
das vokabular falsch finde ich finde es
falsch und flüchtlingskrise zu sprechen
das ist eine migrations krise und allein
durch die dadurch dass sich dieser
begriff flüchtling durchgesetzt hat ist
die debatte im grunde schon schief aber
mehr möchte dazu nichts sagen auch die
gefallen hat das falsche sagen zusagen
zum jahr der woche heißt das geflüchtete
flüchtender ist auch schon
meine eltern sind geflüchtet zum
beispiel meines alters und aus dem
kommunismus geflüchtet beide wie mein
vater von den feldern von der
anrückenden sorge jetzt meine immer an
meiner mutter von den ungarn
verschwanden worden es waren also vor
den anrückenden russen in ungarn es fand
wir hatten die hatten angst vor die
hatten angst vor
vergewaltigungen und und schlimmsten
repressalien meine mutter ist nachts
durch den vierwaldstättersee geflüchtet
geflüchtet also das ist für mich ein
flüchtlinge und ich finde was wir heute
ich finde dann selbstverständlich noch
wirtschaftlicher not ist ein kann ein
legitimer grund für migration seien aber
ich finde allein dass sich dieser
begriff flüchtling flüchtlingskrise auch
durchgesetzt hat auch dass wir das jetzt
in weißrussland sehen dass sie ja gibt
es denn der gezielt eingesetzte
migranten das sind der das in der ecke
das sind ken anderson zumeist ich
menschen die in not sind diese jetzt in
not gebracht worden durch weissrussland
aber ich finde allein die
begriffsverwirrung dass wir einfach
allgemein anerkennen ja weil er sich
nicht durch höhere waren also das waren
ja schon viele aus syrien natürlich aber
es waren ja auch andere aus marokko das
nordafrika die gar keine kämpfe gesehen
haben natürlich natürlich das ist ja
auch nachvollziehbar aber man muss
natürlich aber man differenziert um mit
dem differenziertheit kommt man auch
weiß dass es ja auch die die rolle von
dampf von von den beamten
in der migrationsbehörde und für die ist
es auf jeden fall eine krise bis heute
noch beziehungsweise für die
bundespolizei die die undankbare aufgabe
hat die migranten die kein asyl bekommen
abzuschieben ja jeden verdient kann man
heutzutage abschieben weil wien will man
nach afghanistan abschieben das geht
nicht in so fern bleiben erst mal her
wir brauchen sichere außengrenzen ohne
die wird es nicht gehen und wir brauchen
entsprechend auch ein kluges
einwanderungsgesetz dass es die
möglichkeit gibt hier ein bisschen mehr
zu separieren allein mit dem humanitären
ansatz werden wir da nicht weiter
gekommen